I cut out everything I thought could be  causing inflammation in my body all  grains sugar processed foods soy Dairy  eggs shellfish anything that people are  commonly allergic to or that I had heard  somewhere could cause inflammation I  lost five pounds which wasn't a lot but  I went down three pant sizes and so I  had bloating that I hadn't noticed I'd  had disappeared but more importantly  this blistering rash which was awful it  healed for the first time in almost a  year and a half and then the pain in my  shoulders when I was sleeping went away  and that was within the first month of  eliminating a lot of these foods from my  diet then I really got interested in  this